foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsey personality
co-host of the Uber popular smart money
happy hour that he and Rachel Cruz do as
a podcast on the Ramsay networks he's my
co-host today open phones here as we
talk about you right in front of you
it's your life baby let's talk about it
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Anthony starting off this hour in San
Francisco hey Anthony what's up
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can I help
yeah well first of all happy early
Father's Day
um and um my wife well I started
listening to you about a year and a half
ago and I got my wife
um recently new wife in like into you as
well so we're both on the same plan and
have the same head on and my question is
um we want to purchase a house within
the next year or two and we've the only
debt we have right now is student debt
that we've been saving
um over the last year and my question is
whether we should pay it off all now
um but wondering if that will affect our
credit score with trying to purchase a
home within the next year well George
you did this yeah uh living this out
I've paid off student loans and I bought
a house without a credit score so the
question I think you're asking is how
will it affect it in the meantime if I'm
in that weird in between because when
you pay off your student loans is that
all of your debt
yes that's all our debt yes before he
goes on let me ask you a question do you
have enough money in the bank right now
to pay off the student loan
we do we both do oh okay so you can just
write a check and be done today
and then you want to buy a house about a
year from now
correct okay making sure I have my facts
right okay so your emergency fund will
you have that in place
already or well you need to build that
up after you pay off this debt
yeah so I guess it's kind of scrambled a
total student debt between both of us is
about 56 000. and we have about
seventy thousand in our savings
and I also uh we also have together uh
about twenty thousand in individual
account with uh Schwab cool okay good so
that'll leave you with about thirty four
thousand if you cash out what's in that
account that'll leave you thirty four
thousand let's call your emergency fund
somewhere is it 15 to 20 for you guys
three to six months of expenses
yes that's about right okay and then
you've got a little starter down payment
fund with the rest of that money so you
got about twenty thousand towards your
down payment and you got a year to
finish saving up right
yes okay so we're gonna tell you to pay
off your student loans today when you
get home tonight go honey we're getting
ready to be debt free watch push this
button
so then in six to 12 months after you
pay off your debt that credit score will
disappear once you close all your
accounts and then your credit score will
disappear now there's a chance you get
the house and they run the credit and
you still have a credit score and it's
probably still going to be a good score
and that's fine you can still get a
house that way but there's really no
your credit score is not going to go
down to you know uh 600 all of a sudden
because you paid off your loans you have
any credit cards open
um we do but we pay it off close them
too close them too that'll keep your
credit score open what we're trying to
do is make have zero credit activity
which will make your credit score
completely disappear in six to nine
months zero credit score sets you up for
manual underwriting which is where they
just check your job check your deposit
like we used to back in the day when
people had since
back in the day when people had to
actually qualify for a mortgage and a
monkey can give you a mortgage Now by
looking at a number credit score and uh
but yeah but but we used to actually
make sure people had the money to pay
the bill and stuff and it's called
underwriting the loan manual
underwriting is what's called now as
opposed to not underwriting it and so uh
that's what George did he went with a
zero credit score into Churchill
Mortgage and got a mortgage on his first
home did I have that right yeah and
there was Anthony there's going to be so
many friends and family that go you're
crazy it's going to be so much more
expensive it's going to take forever
it's going to be impossible don't listen
to them because they've never done it
and so I'm telling you it's not going to
be that difficult it's not going to take
a lot more time there's going to be a
few more extra documents and as long as
you stick to that 15-year fixed with at
least 10 percent down you're going to
get a really great competitive interest
rate with Churchill Mortgage not all
mortgage companies know how to do this
Anthony yes so you can't run over it
some stupid place like Bank of America
because they won't know their butt from
a home my lender said they won't do it
you got to stick with one that actually
knows what they're doing yeah you gotta
you got to get with somebody like
Churchill they they because we've
endorsed Churchill for almost 30 years
and because I've told people to not
borrow money Churchill has obviously
system-wide learned to and managed their
whole process to being able to do manual
underwriting because a lot of Ramsey
people don't have a credit score because
all of us got rid of our debt and our
credit we don't use credit or debt but
now if you keep those stupid credit
cards open you may end up with a 650 and
it's going to screw you up so you can't
half butt do this Anthony
you got to decide is yours isn't you and
you got to lean in and push all the way
through uh so ish will get you in a
middle ground you don't want to be in
and I don't suggest that if you're going
to do that then just stay in debt son
yeah this idea of the credit score is
hilarious to me and once you get the
mortgage there's no reason you would
ever need a score at all even though you
don't need one for the mortgage because
people the only reason people hang on to
it is the wedding cake what if Dave what
if we need to go into that you know if I
was um if I was in the banking business
I would invent a thing that said you
need to go get a credit card so you can
build up this number
so that you can get a car loan so that
you can build up this number so that you
can get a student loan so that you can
build up this number so that you can get
a home mortgage
because you need this number and I would
teach you to worship at the altar of the
great FICO because I would tell you that
FICO was your great provider and that
your life on the planet will be somehow
substandard if you don't have this
number it almost sounds like Revelations
yeah this is conspiracy level Theory
right here and it's the only number that
we obsess over more than our weight
those three digits man we are so
obsessed we brag about it we the culture
not you and me we Dave and I would be a
really sad story obsess overweight
unless it's a lack of it I don't share
those numbers Dave okay and my credit
score uh I would share some of my
numbers with you but it wouldn't help
either one I'll take one for the team
Dave you can donate some to me oh but it
really is a wild thing that our culture
has become so obsessed so here's the
interest you you know I have to teach
this like and have for 30 years you
could get a million dollar inheritance
your FICO score doesn't want change one
penny it is not an indication of
financial well-being our Financial
Health it's an indication mathematically
the algorithm them by which they used
the math they used to build the FICO
score is 100 based on how much you play
kissy face with the bank
if you don't play kiss your face with
the bank if you're not making out with
Bank of America you're not getting a
FICO score
I mean this is not hard people if you if
you if you get a million dollar a year
raise at your office today everyone will
wonder why and your FICO score will not
change one point and you won't care
about your FICO score then yes and we'll
change one point it's not an indication
you're winning with money you can be
broke but deeply in debt and have an 800
credit score which matter of facts about
the only way to have an 800 credit score
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we are so glad you are here
today's question of the day is sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
as the weather warms up neighborly can
help you find local service pros like
the ground Skies five-star painting and
mosquito Joe to turn your outdoor space
into your favorite space it's a great
company find the help you need at
neighborly.com today today's question
comes from Chris in Missouri I've heard
some people say that when it comes to
budgeting that I should only live on 50
percent of my income save 25 and invest
25 percent that's dumb is it practical
for me to only live on half my income
and is this the best way for me to begin
saving and investing who are these
people to say this who these people are
they said and I heard or horrible
financial planning firm
wow okay so whoever these people are
they're going real aggressive on all
fronts so we recommend investing 15 once
you're out of debt there's no real
savings goal beyond that other than your
normal goals and your emergency fund
have that in place before you invest and
then as far as your expenses it's a
great thing to learn to live on less
than you make there's no certain
percentage it's all very variable on
your life circumstance your family your
cost of living
all of those things so but you have to
live one lesson you make or you end up
in debt are broke and bankrupt one of
the two I mean but yeah or or both
you'll be okay if you live this way I
just think it's a tough goal that's just
weird though I mean I don't know who
came up with that that doesn't work so I
will tell you George that you know when
we were laying out the baby steps we
started a thousand dollars a little
starter emergency fund then you get out
of debt you build your full emergency
fund three to six months baby step four
save 15 of your income for retirement
you know five as kids college so we have
these very specific buckets that you're
investing in naming and giving admission
to the dollars uh back when I was
putting all that together one of the
things I read was a wonderful quote from
the uh uh there was a Great Awakening a
great Revival that swept Across America
in the frontier days John Wesley the
Wesleyan the father of the Wesleyan
Church the Methodist Church and um
he said famously that if you give 10
save 10 and live on 80 you'll always be
okay
and of course you know that's not a
really that's not a bad formula but we
decided to instead give very specific
goals
to you know tithing for those of us that
are Christians that's what he was
referring to but but on the giving side
but on the other side very specific
goals and very nuanced and so at baby
step two we teach you to save zero
and put it all on the debt until you get
out of debt
so that you get rid of the payments so
you got more money to invest and to give
and so it's kind of a almost our things
more of an intermittent fasting thing
right there we go you know you're just
before that did I just say something
modern that's how history is scary right
he was doing it before it was cool yeah
that's it Jane's in Kalamazoo Michigan
hi Jane welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
well um I I've been listening to you for
a little while now and you seem to
frequently I know the differences
um I'm wondering why you tend to favor
the roths and I could tell you why my
financial advisor originally put all my
money into a traditional
um if you want to hear that
well tradition uh uh it's possible that
your financial advisor fell in the same
hole that other financial advisors fell
in uh and couldn't get out and that hole
was the the in order for the traditional
to work out ahead of the Roth
mathematically you have to be in a lower
tax bracket dramatically at retirement
than you are now uh a dramatically lower
tax bracket which by the way means you
haven't got any money
because if you've got five million
dollars your required minimum
distributions at 70 and a half are going
to put you in the same tax bracket
you're in now
so you're not going to be in a lower tax
bracket and so the Roth absolutely
mathematically kicks the traditionals
but
and here's why if you take two hundred
dollars a month from age 25 to age 65 40
years and you invest that in a decent
growth stock mutual fund you're gonna
have two and a half million dollars in
there however only 96 000 of the two and
a half million is actual
principle that you put in so if you did
a traditional in that you would have
gotten a tax break on ninety six
thousand dollars you would have not paid
taxes yet on ninety six thousand but
you'll pay taxes on the entire two and a
half million as you pull it out if
instead you did this with a Roth you
would pay taxes on the ninety six
thousand and zero taxes on the rest of
the two and a half million
so there's no way
that the traditional even comes close to
the Roth mathematically does that help
you
my
yes when I was I'm retired now but when
I was making a decent salary
um he I wasn't obviously in a higher tax
bracket than I am now that I'm retired
and so
um he's moving
slowly every year a certain amount from
the traditional into the Roth to still
keep me in a very low tax bracket that's
good that's a smart that that is a smart
move but he assumed that you weren't
going to have enough at your required
minimum distribution because you know in
my example you got a tax write-off on
ninety six thousand dollars and then you
still end up paying the taxes on it when
you pull it out later
and so it just doesn't make sense at all
now um when Ross first came out they
really took the nerd population of
financial planners and blew their brains
out I mean they their minds they just
were in a hurricane they didn't know
what to do and I was one of them I I
spent numerous hours crunching numbers
trying to figure out this thing and
here's the other interesting thing
George is when you compare apples to
apples
what we would all do in those days is we
were trying to do the proper math
calculation so if you're going to say
all right a hundred dollars going into a
Roth
requires because you got to pay taxes
that's net of taxes so to put a hundred
into a Roth you actually have to make
130.
right yes so we would say all right 130
going into a traditional or a hundred
going into a Roth because that's a
correct set of mathematical assumptions
for a math nerd and if you're a
financial planner you usually are super
math nerd right now here's the problem
with that that's not what people do
regardless of the tax nutrition that
they forget that taxes have already come
out I've already got the taxes out of my
Roth but I'm still going to fully fund
the eight thousand dollars to six
thousand dollars right yeah I'm gonna
still Max the thing out I'm still going
to put the exact same percentage of my
income into the Roth 401k at my work
even though there's it's net of taxes
it's it's I mean it took more money to
get that in there yeah than it did to do
that in traditional but no one ever goes
you know I'm going to put 80 into my
Roth instead of a hundred into my
traditional they don't reduce it they
just put the same amount in yeah and so
you end up with a Roth we cheat you we
trick you into saving more by accident
you didn't even know it no one no one's
called in saying Dave I did Roth like
you told me to I got too much money in
retirement what do I do I've never had
anybody no I followed your plan on on
getting a match first and then getting
all the Roth I could get and then doing
traditional and I ended up with millions
of dollars and I hate Dave Ramsey I have
never had had that complaint
never and on top of that there's no
required minimum distributions on the
Roth IRA so that's a big bonus as well
and when I get to retirement I don't
want to be worried about tax brackets
and how much income I can withdraw I
just want to live and give like no one
else and not have to worry about that so
Jane where you have ended up today
you're getting good advice on the
gradual move so as not to bump your tax
bracket because whatever you pull out
from under the traditional move it to
the Roth is not going to be subject to
require minimum and it's going to grow
from this point forward tax-free but
you're not you're doing you're moving it
gradually so as not to bump up a tax
bracket and that's good advice the
advice that got you here however is a
bad advice
you should I wish you were all in Roth
right now you'd be in much better shape
you wouldn't have any of this discussion
going on and you probably have more
money so but but it's not the end of the
world you did good and you've retired
you got a chunk of money and you and so
you and I got the opportunity to talk
theory and that's awesome I love it I
love it I love it I love it so the rule
is rock paper scissors but except
there's only one way to go okay
match
beats Roth
a hundred percent match before you get
started you can't beat you can't beat
that math right
Beach Roth Roth Beach traditional so do
all the mats you can all the Roth you
can and only then do you do traditional
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Reuben
and Andrea are with us hey guys how are
you good good welcome where do you guys
live uh English Indiana what's that near
it's about an hour west of Louisville
okay cool yeah I know right where you
are yeah very cool welcome to Nashville
and how much data have you guys paid off
we've paid off 252
852 dollars way to go how long did that
take
48 months wow and your range of income
during that four years uh we started at
150 000 and we're ending at 220. wow
what do you all do for a living
I do construction I own my own business
with my dad and his brother and then I
work as a problem manager for a
agriculture Financial lender ah very
good good for you guys so what kind of
debt was the 253 thousand
uh heavily student loans a tiny bit of
medical debt and then our mortgage oh
you paid off your house yes looking at
weird people yep very nice what's the
house worth
or our property's worth about 450 right
now excellent and how much have you guys
got in your nest egg your 401ks and Roth
irasis stuff
probably around 200 or so very good
you're gonna be baby steps millionaires
soon yes yep well done how old are you
two
I'm 29. no I'm 32. you know I paid four
house that's weirdos extra weird feels
good I love it well done okay so what
happened four years ago you must have
got married we did we did
it was right around time we were getting
married that way you started this steps
I was we were over at one of her friends
houses and
they were talking about Dave Ramsey and
I didn't know much of it and I was on
Facebook at the time when I get home you
pop up on my Facebook ads click on it
watch the video and then I started
listen to your podcast and I was pretty
much game over from there oh so uh
Andrea he got addicted huh he did he
very much did I'm sorry what was your
first reaction to all this when he was
like Hey you gotta listen to this Dave
Ramsey guy yeah well I mean I get
excited pretty easy so I was super on
board like he he seriously came home and
said we need to cut up the credit cards
and we literally did that same day and
then
I don't know it probably didn't even
take a week later and I was like I don't
know what we're doing
I just jumped in the pool I'm not sure I
could swim
deep in literally two years before we
were talking about her student loans
they made you after she graduated
college they made us basically a lot
amount of money you know to pay each
month towards it and it looked like it
was going to take his 20 years basically
it's the plan we were on and
then wait it took us no time after that
yeah you scared of your hope that you
can do it yeah and you knock it out in
48 months house and everything while
we're at it Mike you're up that's wild
you went from a 20-year plan to a
four-year plan with the house what made
you guys push on through after the
Consumer Debt was gone
I just said why not like we came this
far yeah exactly wow yeah while we're at
it well we got the momentum yeah push it
all the way through wow so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you're 29 years old yo paid for
house you're almost millionaires already
um I'd say communication we yeah we tell
all our friends all the time that it
felt more like marriage counseling than
a financial plan because it that
communication piece was the biggest
thing yeah and budgeting helped a lot
too like we were just spending money on
stupid stuff we didn't really need and
what's the dumbest thing you bought when
you're doing stupid stuff
huh that's a good question
it was more like just like we had uh
like Netflix Hulu we had all those
things that like even way more I don't
know yeah those automatic subscriptions
I would just take money out and have to
look at it you don't look it you don't
care what it is just fill a buggy up
right go to Costco yeah exactly yeah
yeah wow I was just reading a stab at 51
of those who make six figures are
paycheck to paycheck right which is just
wild and you guys were those people yeah
we were one of those people we made good
money and it's all just disappearing yep
what were the Tactical things you did to
actually get control once you started
looking at this uh the monthly meeting
yeah monthly meeting was very yeah very
much so that made us stay on track and
especially like I was the spender and
Reuben was the saver so making sure we
stayed together and communicated and
stuck to that because that was I mean
that was hard like you very much had to
Wrangle me in it yeah it was rough at
times but I had to do it what was the uh
what was the one biggest fight you
remember going out with friends we had
to slow that down a little bit it yeah
that was pretty much so that was amazing
that was hard we our biggest Chunk we
paid off the like 90-ish thousand
between February 2019 and April 2020.
whoa right in it that was in the thick
of it and then covered and shut down
like that was it was a tough time yeah
yeah it's very hard hard for everybody
but yeah it's hard to be sacrificial in
the middle of that mess yeah way to go
you guys excellent excellent work okay
and you got kiddos we do we do are they
here they are here okay we'll bring them
up here let's get them in the shot okay
what are their names and ages uh Ruby
he's about to be two and then Rory she's
about to be one all right very cool oh
good looking guys what a great family
those kids don't even know what their
mom and dad have done their whole family
tree has changed I'm so proud of y'all
well done hey we've got the uh live and
give box for you that's The Total Money
Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book both number one
bestsellers for you to read or give
whatever you're going to do there and of
course Financial Peace University as
well uh you can use that or give it away
too so way to go you guys Reuben and
Andrea Ruby and Rory from English
Indiana 253 thousand dollars paid off in
48 months making 150 to 220. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two two one
[Applause]
I love it
so George A buddy of mine was telling me
he was looking at uh Twitter I don't
look at Twitter as you know it's full of
crap and uh he said you know half the
people on there like Dave Ramsey doesn't
know how to make people millionaires he
goes you're making millionaires all the
time out of all the things they want to
come at you for that's what they chose I
mean isn't that funny because those guys
right there are 29 years old they're
almost millionaires we put people on the
air all the time that have just said I
followed your plan and I'm a millionaire
yeah look at that I don't know how much
more social proof that's not for rich
people it's for poor people Dave Ramsey
stuff I think you're an idiot if you say
that I mean because the actual the the
data is that we may have made more
millionaires than anyone else in America
yeah no I mean we didn't do it but we
show show more people how to become and
they did go do it then you know so
because the trick here is this listen
hey what's the number one cause of
divorce in North America today money
fights money problems what'd she say
marriage is better communication what's
the number one thing communication three
different times yeah she said I'm the
spender communication communication
accountability we had to learn to work
together we had to hold each other
accountable communication marriage is
increased
dead is gone thought they were going to
be under the thumb of the student loan
debt for 20 years and no four years
later while we're at it let's just pay
off the house too
it's amazing I'm so proud of them
they're neat wow amazing amazing Heroes
and I hope there's other people out
there who are going we make over a
hundred thousand dollars and yet we're
broke with payments up to our eyeballs
and subscriptions we forgot about and we
thought we were going to pay off debt
maybe 20 years from now we'll retire one
day and instead they took control alone
comes Ruben and Andrea to bust your
little idea yep those little kids will
do that to you they cash for those
babies in the middle of all this well
just drop that in there why don't we
crazy yeah way to go guys so very cool
listen when you take control of your own
life in a world that tells you you're a
victim
you're what's called a hero
they're rare they're rare it's someone
who stands up throws their shoulders
back and says
not me I'm not a victim I mean because
there's plenty of people out there will
tell you that you're stuck that's easy
to do people like us well our
millionaire study days of people like us
what the crap does that mean we found 97
of the millionaires we studied believe
they had control over their own
financial destiny well isn't that
interesting well I mean once you've
ridden a bike you ask people that know
how to ride a bike is it possible to
ride a bike yeah or something would say
yeah I think we can ride a bike because
I'd like to do it fairly often this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so that couple that
paid off 253 000 in 48 months also we
were talking to them at the break went
through Financial Peace University see
and he said he never misses a podcast
you can listen to this podcast and know
all the answers and not do it
and you'll still be broke and stressed
and no wealth
why because knowing what to do with your
money isn't the problem doing it is what
you have to do you actually have to do
it yeah
knowing that Donuts will make you fat
means you have to quit eating them not
just knowing it right I know this from
personal experience I can tell you okay
personal finance is 80 Behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge The Proven way to
change your behavior is get in a system
like Financial Peace University it's the
most well-known most popular uh actually
most effective uh personal finance class
in history if you have really 10 million
people have been through this this is
why this class has worked we it's like
having a personal trainer you got a
coordinator that's a superhero that's in
your corner they're going to hold you
accountable they're going to love you
encourage you when you're scared show
you what to do and become you know in a
sense like a coach right hey Financial
Peace University sign up at
ramsesolutions.com FPU
ramseysolutions.com
FPU Brandon is in Jackson Mississippi hi
Brandon welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so uh my question is should I live
closer to work uh renting an apartment
buying a clunker vehicle as I hear so
many times or should I do should I keep
paying my 2023 Honda Civic off uh and
drive two hours Monday through Friday to
work an hour to an hour from
um I don't know why these things
necessarily go together
um I well personally cannot imagine
driving that much to work
my commute is 12 minutes
and I would change my life if it was two
hours so
um why do you want to drive that far and
why does that sound appeal I mean you
could live close to work and have a
Civic
right so they're not mutually exclusive
well there's uh there's more to it yeah
I guess so my yeah so I I am I am 30 and
I do still live with my parents and that
that's that's the I I that's kind of the
thing it's like well uh I don't I don't
think I'm making it for mortgage for a
mortgage or anything and I'm thinking
well maybe uh maybe I need to
um maybe I need to have them
maybe I need to rent somewhere or
I'm not entirely sure let's catch back
up how old are you
30. okay and what do you make
I make about 46 yeah I'll make forty six
thousand a year how much was the Civic
Civic was 25 and my parents paid it up
my parents paid it and I'm paying them
back 500 a month oh
dude that car is a large portion of your
world so you're saying the other option
is we sell the car and get a clunker and
then go live on your own closer to work
yes yes I was trying to I like that
earlier yeah that's a great plan
compared to your life right now you're
chained to a car and it's making you
live with your parents when you're 30.
and having a multiple hour commute yeah
there's nothing in there there's nothing
in this story is fun
there's no fun here
no yeah I mean I'm not sure how big of a
clunker you have to do but you
definitely need to get rid of this car
regardless of where you live because
it's more than half your annual income
you have too much tied up in car and um
yeah I
I think you already know what you're
supposed to do
you just wanted us to tell you
yeah
yeah it's it's
a reliability thing that's
not what I'm talking about I think
you're ready to not live with your
parents you're 30.
yeah I'm I am you need to move you want
your dignity yeah right now your growth
has been and what's keeping you from
doing that is the car
right yeah so what they thought was a
blessing actually actually has caused
them to have a 30 year old in their
basement so it's not a blessing so um
because you know they there's a part of
them that wants rid of you and there's a
part of them that wants you to stay
forever that's all parents we don't want
our children to leave we love our
children assuming they're functional and
not crazy and all that but I mean most
of us love our kids and we would we want
to be around them I I love my grown
children I've got a you know kids in
their 30s right and grandbabies I love
them all I don't want any of them living
with me though now I'm done with that
I figured out I can love them better
when they're not there
it's amazing how that works yeah move
out get rid of the car get you a cheaper
car get you a better life two hour
commute sucks big car payment sucks
living with Mom when you're 30 sucks
let's undo the sucks man
really what do you think yeah I'm I'm
with it and Dave I've got so much Flack
lately I've been uploading videos on my
YouTube channel about car buying car
leases how dumb they are how your car
payment is costing you six million
dollars and the little whiners don't
like it well they go you can't get a use
oh my gosh he wants us to die in a fire
on the interstate oh my God driving
these used cars Hey listen time to fire
on the interstate you drive a Tesla come
on yeah I'm already living on the edge
yeah I mean you're like you're tired
you're dying on a fire in there looking
for a place to happen so
I'm just Brave I know you are you are
you have great courage but this idea
that a used car is somehow way more
unreliable what's interesting is if you
buy a brand new car and you have it for
two years do you have any idea what
you're driving a used car
how is it reversible that all used cars
are unreliable that's a dumb butt
statement
that's dumb especially cars as well as
they're made today the quality of
vehicles today I just saw that we have a
200 000 mile Civic and it's still a
great car they sent me a video of this
Toyota that had one million miles on it
and it was still running yeah I'd go
down but it was impressive this idea
that if it's over a hundred thousand
miles change your oil hello change your
oil this is not rocket science yeah but
I mean I'm gonna die in a fire on the
interstate we're just kind of wilting
snowflake comment is that well it's I've
got a dire and a fire on the inner you
are a drama freaking Queen they
catastrophize that and worse than that
you posted that on a YouTube video there
was someone else's what jeez I know
these are the YouTube comments that I
love to read Dave just to Riley I think
I can hear your mother's helicopter
blades in the background
something safe and reliable yeah no
gluten I'm just saying oh my gosh wow
uh a lot of time to be alive I'm telling
you man jeez I am I I am turning into
that get off my lawn guy and we're all
here for it oh you're here to watch it
only helps the ratings
oh my gosh but here's the thing if
you're gonna buy a used car people in
Dave you've been saying for years get
the beater car get the beater car well
yes the beater cars are more expensive
than they were you may not be able to
find the thousand dollar beater car it
may be a five thousand dollar business
how is your income your income's gone up
and get a pre-purchase inspection for a
hundred bucks so you know you're not
buying a lemon that's riddled with
issues and you'll be just fine that's
all it takes
but I'm done with these this excuse that
I need a 35 000 car because the five
thousand dollar one is going to end me
in a fight on the interstate
it doesn't matter
just admit that you're justifying a bad
purchase that's okay uh
be honest with yourself it was
Suffocation of America oh my gosh you're
gonna die in a fire on this I'm not
being a fan down by the river that's now
a dream for many people Dave that's not
even the worst case scenario yeah I
talked to a lady out here the other day
young lady she said she's a digital
Nomad oh that's a neat word for homeless
but it's digital now so it's digitally
homeless yeah I'm digitally a nomad yeah
I'm just not just a nomad I'm not a
digital Nomad which means your avatar is
actually homeless too yeah so
I'm gonna become that old man going kids
these days in the digital cats can't get
nothing no hey guys listen we don't want
you if you'll drive like no one I didn't
drive over here in a five thousand
dollar car
I drove over here in a really nice I
parked next to him I can vouch it was
nice it was a fun I really wanted my
commute to be a little longer today
because it's that much fun to drive that
freaking car
but I drove pieces of crap for a few
years so that I can drive anything I
want now drive like no one else so that
later you can drive like no one else
live like no one else so that later you
can live like no one else one definition
of maturity emotional psychological and
spiritual maturity is the ability to
delay pleasure and not be whining the
whole time
[Music]
call the wambulance this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage in the studios it's
the Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsey personality
co-host of the really really popular
smart money happy hour he and Rachel
Cruz do that together Ramsey
personalities it comes out a couple
times a week now George every Thursday
we're here once a week if we could do
more we would the people are clamoring
like there is a lot of clamoring so much
I have heard clamoring I've heard it out
there about smart money happy hour
Sharon Ramsey is a fan and that's the
only one I care about well I mean um
that's good job security yes because
um she probably carries more weight
around here than I do so Dave's not
going to shut down a podcast that his
wife loves yeah just have to have a real
good explanation you know one of y'all
gonna screwed up bad but hey it's
working real good Ramsey networks is
exploding and smart money happy hour is
part of that the Dr John deloney show is
part of that the Ken Coleman show is
part of that check it all out we're glad
you're here thank you for being with us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Chris is with us
Chris is in Dallas hi Chris how are you
hey Dave I'm doing well how are you
doing today better than I deserve sir
how can I help
so I had a question regarding the
decision to pay off student loans versus
paying off the home early and I know the
date the baby step program I'm a big fan
of it I was on step seven I was I was a
younger guy you know in my 20s and I was
living at home so I had no mortgage to
pay no kids and I was saving every dime
that I had
um to hopefully put a down payment on a
house
last year I got I got married in 2022 I
had sixty thousand dollars saved up I
was debt free no assets other than my
car and my car was paid off on my
personal belongings
um now that we're married her income is
about a hundred and ten thousand dollars
now when we when we got married I moved
into an 86 000 town home
and as of last year when we first got
married adk was remaining on the
mortgage this is a 3.25 mortgage rate
she also has 45 000 in student loan debt
that I knew about before we got married
and she was aggressively paying it off
um so I'm I'm hoping that this question
might resonate with some of your your
younger viewers uh sub struggling with
excessive in the loan debt
um we know that the Supreme Court is
still waiting to do their ten thousand
dollar loan forgiveness but if I'm being
completely honest I don't think it's
gonna happen
um the pause is ending in a couple of
months and I believe the loans will
start occurring interest in either I
think it's September I think the
payments are going October but the loans
are actually a cure interest in
September so we're looking to you know
make a big decision here of either
paying off the remaining balance of the
mortgage or paying off those student
loan debts and part of that is the fear
of uncertainty
um with the economy and with the
inflation Germany you know declared a
recession I think it was last week it's
the fourth largest economy
um and that's one of the things that
we're kind of worried about here in the
US is how long are we going to continue
to you know say we're not in a recession
you don't declare a recession and you
don't say
I'm in a recession recession is a
mathematical
thing it's objective it's not subjective
it's two consecutive quarters of the
gross domestic product shrinking rather
than growing
that is the definition of a recession no
one gets to redecide that that is what
it is
if it's if it's raining outside you will
be wet if it's not raining you will not
be wet regardless of how you feel
right okay so your feelings don't matter
and Germany didn't declare a recession
they admitted statistically that they
were in one I assume I didn't see that
article but don't really give a crap
Germany's economy is not really relevant
it's it you know what matters here is
what matters here so I do you believe
that the American economy is going to
collapse Chris
I don't think it's going to collapse
okay then stop this
what is all the real question is
justifying hanging on to all this debt
because I really don't think it's you're
not really that worried about the
recession
um I think that we have an
Administration we've been in the
recession politics aside let's just
imagine politics doesn't exist no we're
not a recession
but we we were last year yeah and did
you realize there was a half of a
percent one quarter and a quarter of a
percent another quarter it's the
lightest recession ever that you could
call a recession I'm not defending Biden
and I'm certainly don't think it's a
wonderful thing but dude we're far from
the Great Depression and you being in a
bread line and unable to pay your bills
right quit watching the news and get off
the internet man
go out in the sun
yeah you're done you're killing me I
understand that yeah I I pay off your
student loans first and then pay off
your house Chris how much money do you
have
we have so we we've been paying the
house down we have the problem with
paying off student loans during the
freeze right is there's a zero percent
interest on that there's not a problem
they will take your money
write them a check and be done with it
but
Ally savings account is giving us four
percent oh my goodness hey Chris no one
ever got rich borrowing on their student
loans and putting in an Allied for God's
sakes
I don't think we're trying to get rich I
think we're trying to just make an
exercise
the balance on the student loans what
the balance of the student loan is 45
000 with the interest rate okay and
you're an ally is paying you how much
allies paying us four percent on Seventy
thousand dollars is about 250 to 300.00
on the 45 is what we're discussing okay
Chris what's four percent of 45
um eight hundred bucks
you know you know what two percent of 45
is because that's your your uh big
leverage deal you're doing here 400
bucks
crap man you spend more on that on pizza
this is you're not getting rid this is
this is intellectual Mumbai mum jumbo
quit trying to beat the system get your
butt out of debt get your house paid off
you believed it before and now you've
been down the black hole somewhere
you're spending too much time on Tick
Tock man really you really do need to
get your head out of them I could have
got a side job and paid off your debts
for you in the time no he's been
researching all this I could have paid
so you got 70 000 in the bank you should
pay it off today and then you ought to
reach over there and y'all be done with
the house by Christmas
you know you want to be you want to be
we're not worried about a recession
here's an idea get get everything paid
off really fast if that's that's just
talking to me about that Allied high
yield account no one ever got rich on a
four percent high yield account and a
nine percent inflationary Market dude
you've lost five percent of your
purchasing power while you're screwing
around discussing this rookies absolute
rookie I'm turning off the headlines
you've been on you've been on I can I
can smell it all you're doing is
re-spouting social media crap you have
been reading to do not if Twitter is
your financial planner if Tic Tac is
helping you with your leverage
discussions you're screwed Chris this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
making your financial decisions and your
analysis
around your financial decisions
here's a couple of rules for you that
the wealthy people do
okay
they make their decisions based on the
principles
that are going to take them to their
goal
now we are sure after 30 years of doing
this
that one principle is your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income and
when you get rid of debt your
probability and speed
by which you become wealthy is increased
the more debt you carry the slower
you run towards being a millionaire
it's a math thing
and all the data is there with all the
people who have done it the second thing
you need to do is
you got to be really careful and this is
a trap I fell into when I was
um young and stupid
uh because I'm really really good with
math
and I'm really a math nerd
way bad like pocket protector
calculator on my belt
math nerd
and if that is you you will get
paralysis of the analysis if you're not
careful what I learned that wealthy
people do is they don't get caught up in
the nuances of the math they do what we
call Big math
meaning they're looking at the big
chunks and where that's taking them and
when I'm doing things here on the air
with you I don't use a calculator I
don't need one because I'm typically not
doing nuanced mathematics I am looking
at the big chunks now what I mean by
that is if the big the the
if you do nuanced math you say oh I have
forty seven thousand dollars in an
Allied account that pays me four percent
why would I pay that off a student loan
that is two percent
or a mortgage that is two percent I'm
making for
I'm sorry no I'm sorry I'm making four
and the student loan is seven why would
I why would I do that because I'm losing
that money but then you actually do the
math what is four percent of forty seven
thousand dollars it's 800 bucks what is
the spread two percent spread and this
is your leverage Factor
and the whole thing all of this
mathematical theory that you spend all
of your brain power on if you're a super
nerd like me ends up being the cost of a
pizza
which proves that you are concentrating
on the wrong things
the right things to concentrate on are
the big things the things that are going
to take you where you want to go and
it's not am I getting rich on I get
because here's an example okay I use a
Discover card and I get two two percent
back
okay so let's help let me help you with
this you spend a hundred dollars
because it sounds like I got two percent
two percent free two percent two percent
two percent oh God I'm so smart I got
two percent this is a super nerd inside
your brain right but let's do it okay a
hundred dollars spent is how much two
dollars
where was The Wealth building when you
spent a hundred
and you got two
dollars back
you can can you imagine millionaires
sitting around and thinking and going I
think that's great let's do that
no broke people think that's great
and they get all hung up on the two
percent two percent two percent two
percent it's two
dollars
but Dave that's just one of the cards
the other one has a five percent
rotating cash back on restaurants this
month I know so if I eat out enough I
can become a millionaire for my five
percent cash back again let's just take
your whole eating out budget times five
percent and by the way you gave away a
hundred percent you got back five this
is a debt I mean this is a wealth
reduction plan not a wealth increasing
plan because you're consuming 95 of the
money you got five percent back but five
percent ends up being five or fifteen
dollars
I mean guys
you're majoring in minors because you're
super nerding on the math instead of
actually looking at the nominal dollars
that the math creates if you actually
run the math formula out and look at the
number of dollars you go
I'm this is I'm so screwed that I can't
breathe I'm this is dumber than a rock
and I had to learn to do that because
that's what millionaires do it's called
here's it's called common sense
there's a it's not it's not it's not a
math form there's a concept it's it's
when you give away 100 if Little Johnny
gives away 100 and he gets back two how
long does it take little Johnny to
become bankrupt not wealthy but bankrupt
this is a math problem math problem
right there just telling you man wow
yeah and then you get this thing this
thing from NPR this thing right here
yeah I resonated with this because this
is part of this discussion we're having
here's the headline a lack of credit
history creates Financial obstacles for
immigrants and as a first generation
American whose parents were immigrants I
resonated this because I went oh my gosh
this is my parents story here's what it
says what may seem like an immigrant
cliche actually happens every day
foreigners arrive in the U.S with Big
Dreams and a few dollar bills in their
wallet that was true for both of us
reporting the story
and it goes on to say the U.S economy
counts on you to borrow money and stay
into debt and the epitome of all this is
the credit score which often snares
newcomers into a financial Catch 22
penalizing a lack of dead history and
pushing many to take confusing sometimes
costly measures
besides that we need to support the U.S
economy because that's our first goal
my first goal is not to support the U.S
economy my first goal is to make sure
the Ramsey family is taken care of the
US economy will have to deal with itself
they'll figure it out
on you it counts on you welcome to
America stay in debt you need a credit
score to live here that's pretty much
what they tell you and so how do you get
a credit score Dave well you got to go
into debt to get the score so you can go
into more debt to get the score so you
can go into that to get the score oh my
God so the Great American dream when you
add
um this method to it turns into the
Great American Nightmare for a lot of
first generation immigrants oh yeah and
they play this game because they were
told they had to play the game and then
they realize wait where's the American
dream we're broke up to our eyeballs in
car loans credit cards personal loans
student loans medical debt mortgages now
your family was Middle Eastern yes so uh
we've done a lot of work in the Spanish
Community uh people coming from various
countries uh in the Latin world and a
lot of them don't have a trust of banks
and so they haven't fallen for this if
they're particularly their entry-level
socio-economic okay now if they come in
higher heavier cash users yeah the
heavier complete it's under the bench
it's literally in a box under the bed I
mean I'm not kidding it's not a metaphor
it's a shoe box with hundred dollar
bills you know the bet because they
don't trust Banks to not go broke from
because they came from a Banana Republic
of some kind that all the bank banking
system was not reliable and so they
don't fall for this because they're not
going to go into debt now what they do
fall for is other things Title Pawn and
other crap you know but uh but what
happens is people like your mom and dad
they often get Americanized in the worst
ways
they adapt to the culture and part of
that is this toxic money culture that
says you got to go into debt and where
does that lead us well U.S household
debt now surpasses 17 trillion dollars
now here's what's interesting Dave
comparing that to the European Union
which has more households and yet less
than half of that amount in debt which
tells me that debt is the most
aggressively marketed product in
American history and we are so good
America is number one in a lot of things
and debt is one of them marketing is one
of them and here's a great quote from a
Stanford economic sociologist being
financially responsible in the U.S has
come to mean and borrow and repay
that pretty much sums up how you've been
doing this for 30 years Dave
everyone was told if you want to be
financially responsible borrow money and
repay it back and do that over and over
again until you die and then maybe one
day you'll hopefully be able to retire
insane so I think it's time for a
cultural shift here well I yeah you just
want to you want to say hey don't you
know you got here for the Statue of
Liberty don't give up your Liberty
um don't don't sign up for slavery come
here for freedom and you lose it yeah
the first day sign up for master
card
that's your first thing to do once
you're looking for Liberty but you go
get a master first thing
yeah that's not our American distress we
can sign up for that or discovering
bondage yeah all for two percent back
don't forget
two dollars land of the free home of the
broke two dollars
two dollar Bob two dollars
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage age
Sean is with us hey Sean how are you
hello hello how you guys doing today
better than we deserve sir where do you
live
um Houston Texas sir cool welcome to
Nashville and how much debt have you
paid off sir well Dave 63 000 and two
pesky dollars
oddly enough excellent dude how long did
this take about 13 months good for you
and your your range of income during
that time started at 52-5 and ended at
80 000. okay good for you man and uh
very very cool what kind of debt was the
63 000. well it was a 58 000 in uh
student loans had about 2 400 and
personal loans and then the rest was
credit card debt sir so you just knocked
the student loans out just knock on
Sally May out had to slay the dragon at
the slay the dragon get that ugly woman
out of my house absolutely Victor yes
sir I like it I like it I like it well
done so what happened 13 months ago
where you went all right I'm gonna stop
being normal and just collecting debt
like Monopoly chips here well I uh I got
my first big boy job and I was like okay
making some good money now it's time to
be a better student or my money and then
I started buying trips to this flight to
Denver this flight to Phoenix and then I
realized oh man it's not working up so I
decided to look up how to handle my
personal finance on YouTube
and I fell asleep watching videos and
then two o'clock in the morning I see a
video of a guy with a chain around his
neck and talking about
um the bar is slave to the lender
I uh
it's funny because as soon as uh that
happened my TV just turned off and I
fell asleep but when I woke up the very
first thought of my head was the
borrower slave to lender so I said you
know what I need to learn more about
Dave so I started watching more videos
watching more videos and Dave you gave
me the best Christmas gift I could ever
ask for it was uh 2021 and you had given
a 14 day free trial at FPU and three
days into that free trial I already saw
all the videos
and then two days after that I bought a
year membership I was like I gotta get
on this I gotta hold myself accountable
wow yes sir went through an FPU class
coordinated FPU class and currently
doing another one trying to help other
people and
um Inspire them as well thank you it's
impossible to lead a class and not do
better at your own money because you
can't be a hypocrite right absolutely
correct absolutely well done man what
transformation thank you thank you boom
boom thank you and 12 13 months not even
just barely over a year I mean it was it
was my it was my full-time job it was a
part-time job it was a doordash and Uber
it was getting at it getting that again
at it just non-stop budgeted and um make
fun of you because you were pretty
intense well I mean the people that made
fun of me that it made me realize maybe
I shouldn't be hanging out with those
people whoa you know maybe I should be
uh surrounding myself with people that
want to be with me for me and circle got
smaller but you know what else got
smaller that debt
that's good
well you become who you hang around with
wow oh very cool man what was the most
lucrative side hustle for you that you
went this one's worth it if someone's
listening out there well actually can I
give a little Side Story sure so my full
time is a as an accountant for a custom
Home Building Company my part-time was
with a fast food company uh Taco Bell
and then I was doing doordash and so I
did 15 hours of my full-time part-time
and then I ended up doing some doordash
and Uber at the end of it I said let me
do it tell me how funny this is how I
know the big man upstairs was watching
because I ended up having a doordash
order to pick up Taco Bell and then I
ended up dropping it off to a house that
my full-time job actually built so it
was a circle it was a full circle of
life
when I saw that and that's when I
realized okay this is meant to happen
this is going to happen I'm gonna be
okay yes sir wow it's very cool so
you're doing accounting part time as
well no so I actually owe you guys a lot
because
um I was I wanted to continue to pursue
it's not only YouTube but it's also the
rest of your team as well you know Ken
John deloney all of them made a big
impact in my life personally
um and I am actually going for my CPA
now
um wow and the thing is I went to the
YouTube Community as well because I was
going to go through a long journey of
that but then somebody was like dude you
could do it this way do it that way and
all of a sudden it made things so much
easier for me the YouTube crazies they
were a big a big part of cheerleaders
yeah they're good cheerleaders they are
they're hardcore too oh yeah they'll
call you out oh yes oh yes well done man
I'm proud of you thank you thank you so
much your biggest in-person cheerleader
oh my family my friends I mean we all
they they thought I was weird at first
because I was barely around but I was
working but then you know once I told
him I was that free they were like what
I had to double check and then it was
like okay all right but but I definitely
you know my mom my dad my little
brothers my little sister my
accountability partner Cynthia
definitely great great great moment love
it yeah you're like the poster child for
all of this stuff man you're incredible
you're a hero how old are you I'm 30
years old sir oh my goodness extra jobs
living on nothing just leaned in 13
months 63
000. yes sir just figured if if uh if I
could climb out of that hole throw some
dirt into that hole and you know thanks
to FPU it gave me a path to move forward
and now my mission is to try to spread
that word to everyone else amen I want
to be in your class yeah really thank
you really he's motivating man that's
very cool congratulations thank you very
very well done man excellent excellent
now that you're done
all that hard work that was a wild year
you had oh yeah how's it feel
ah
yeah there it is that's all I have to
say yeah was it worth it oh yeah most
definitely if I could tell 20 year old
Sean that you know the key to success is
really delayed gratification you know
um and you know just be faithful to what
you really want to aim for amen amen you
know knowing your whys what really gets
you going yeah for real proud of you
absolutely good work good work we got to
see yeah we got the live and give box
for you it's got The Total Money
Makeover book in it you'll give that
away because you know all that stuff the
baby steps millionaires book you're
getting ready to be one of those soon
and you're on your way for sure and
getting ready to be a CPA as well man
what a great story you are and Financial
Peace University membership you can give
that to one of your buddies and maybe
one of those people that thought you
weren't going to do it and get them
going that'll be a cool uh cool Payback
right there so good good stuff Sean from
Houston Texas wow
63 000
thousands making 52 to 80. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream love you
Jerry
three two one
wow
[Applause]
I want to be him when I grow up
so I think it's really important what we
talk about around here is one of the
things that you know we're really good
at information
Ramsay giving you the content giving you
the information the what to do next the
the steps the uh the detail the new the
nuanced answer to your weird question
all that stuff right but but what we're
even better at the the reason that
Ramsay's word is not me but this whole
place of over a thousand of us in the
building is because we actually inspire
you to go do it
and humans Inspire other humans not
information
so what here here's what I think is
really important about his story
took a 14-day free trial completely
binged through the nine lessons
some people go got it turned it off
back to their same old habits good to
know and they just move on with their
life good to know a good point and what
did he do instead he said I need what
was the phrase he said I need the
accountability I need to get all in
and so he said I'm going to go ahead and
even he's already got all the
information now he got got the nine
videos for free in the 14 day free trial
right but instead I'm going now I know
it all no he realized the the secret
sauce is not the information it's the
application
of the doing it
and he said I got to get signed up for
the whole year and he had the humility
to go I need the accountability I know
me I'm self-aware enough to know I need
to go a step further let me help you if
you're human you need accountability
there's no one The Lone Ranger had Tonto
I mean come on everybody we all need
somebody everybody humans is not good
that men be alone bible is real clear
about that and if you if you didn't
think you knew that you discovered it
again back during when we had that
little thing that fault she did that
quarantine thing yeah when he made
everybody sit at home I remember that
you remember that everybody sat at home
got fat and had no humans around them
yeah remember that yeah I remember and
uh yeah we figured out we need humans
humans need people need people it's a
song you know that's a great song well
hey I'm leading an FPU class starting
next week virtually and so if you are
listening to Sean's story you go I need
that it's not too late to join you can
go to fpu.com and sign up for my class
that I'm leading I don't know that I'm
gonna be as good as Sean but I'm
inspired to be as good of a coordinator
I think you guys might be surprised how
mean George is I'm gonna come at you and
we're gonna have a good time come at you
yeah like he's all hopped up on Mountain
Dew well it's the cold brew Dave it
doesn't take much caffeine to go through
my little veins come at you like a
spider monkey
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us America George
Campbell Ramsey personalities my co-host
today John's in Atlantic City hi John
welcome to the Ramsay show
good to talk to you how can we help
all right so I've been listening to you
for the past
um month or so and before that I was
buying real estate but I think you'd
disagree I'm just going to lay out what
I have
um I have 52k in the money market
um
of 8 000 in checking
and
um I have a credit card debt of 9 000
and a car loan of 21
um my wife her only debt is her car
and we have a house that we owe 426 on
and my three rental properties I have I
owe 125 on 126 and 110 but they're all
rented out
so I was going to buy another piece of
real estate but what do you think
I think you should take all that money
in that money market and knock out all
of your debt and leave you with a nice
emergency fund and slow down on all this
real estate investing
until you can get some of it paid off
what's her card at yeah
her cordette
um she's going to be paid off in four
months I'm not sure exactly the number
you don't know what the balance is
no no I just know she's going to be done
in four months or uh payment is so it's
a couple couple thousand bucks in
yeah yeah okay
so you can write a check today and be
debt free am I understanding you right
yeah but then I mean you know I just I
know you're dead against it but I love
having the
the rental properties and having the
money come in but I also understand the
Ramsey Way well here let me how old are
you John
uh 34. okay all right when I was uh 24 I
started buying real estate
and by the time I was 26 I had four
million dollars worth I was aggressively
buying it and I was buying really really
good deals I was buying stuff at uh 70
80 cents on the dollar
and so I had good Equity positions
some of the property I put mortgages on
and I was renting some of it I had
short-term notes on and I was fixing it
and flipping it
during that time that was a long time
ago that was back in the 80s okay during
that time was another that that moment
in time there was a real estate craze
real estate was the answer to everything
like it is right now
everybody's talking about real estate
right now everybody in your age group
the 20s and 30s thing it's all over the
social media it's all over everything
it's like it's like the thing to talk
about like you're cool if you're doing
real estate right now you know it's you
know what I'm talking about it's
everywhere right uh 100 it was that way
then and in those days we didn't have
social media we didn't have the internet
but we had these things called
infomercials that would run at night and
a guy would sit by the the side of the
sea with the waves crashing in and talk
about how wealthy he was and how he had
bought all this real estate nothing down
and you could buy his tape set for three
thousand dollars on how to do it and
that kind of stuff there was a bunch of
those characters out there
um one of them's got a really nice
Winery now in Napa Del dotto and he was
one of the biggest ones uh and uh makes
a great bottle of wine called the beast
side note but anyway the um but anyway
so I was in this group there was a group
of people that started in each City
there was a guy that went around got a
group of people doing nothing down or
low amount down real estate Real Estate
Investors Club
of Nashville and I was in this club with
about 60 people that were doing exactly
what you're doing and that were doing
what I was doing back then okay and
um they were all buying with as little
money as they could put into it and
making the rent you know collecting the
rents and hoping that was going to pay
the bills and so forth now here's the
reason I tell you that long long drawn
out story
mm-hmm no one
from that club
30 years later
is rich
none of them okay
except two guys
wow so you think the best and both of
those guys
worked diligently to reverse the process
and get out of debt
I went bankrupt
while I was in that club I lost
everything at 28 years old
yeah and and so did a whole bunch of
those guys as a matter of fact the guy
that wrote the book called nothing down
named Robert Allen went bankrupt
filed chapter 11.
okay and so the the proof is in the
pudding when you visit it 10 15 20 30 40
years later you can see okay did this
work didn't work the ones the only ones
that worked for were the ones that
reversed the process and cleared the
debt like George just told you to do so
I I love how aggressive you are I love
that you love real estate I love real
estate I've got a bunch of it to this I
mean after I went broke I made a bunch
of money later and I you know I own
several hundred million dollars of real
estate now I think it's an excellent
investment I like real estate but 100 of
my real estate is paid for so George I
mean I I think you're right I would stop
buying I would clear the personal debt
and I clear my my mortgages all of them
including my house and you've got the
ability to do this because dude you're a
go-getter you're a guy that gets crap
done but if you don't watch you're gonna
out you know you're gonna outrun your
coverage
and um that's what scares me with John
I'm looking at a guy he's he's seen his
cash flow from three properties I see a
guy who has eight hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in debt and one misstep
could tank him oh yeah one life
situation is all it takes and so I
understand being kind of starry-eyed
with a pile of money going well that
means more real estate I see it as a we
could get out of debt and reduce our
risk and start you end up with all of
these properties paid for in three to
five years including your residence you
can buy another property a year for cash
with a cash flow you'll create by doing
that that's what I did the second time
the second time I got the first one's
really hard you get these three paid off
that's really hard but you get those
three you get pure cash flow from those
no debt at all you can buy another 100
200 000 property pretty quick because
you'll have enough cash it just piles up
it snowballs in the right direction you
know and that cash will snowball for you
if you're not giving it all to the bank
but uh 100 of the time debt equals risk
more debt equals more risk less debt
equals less risk a hundred percent of
the time and that's why those guys went
broke and they collect well it's amazing
how if you move a little bit slower
right now you can go much faster later
on oh yeah and that's what happens when
you get rid of the debt and you have
more cash flow you're gonna be able to
save up and pay cash for those what
others perceive as faster but yeah the
percentages shift on you because you
know once I got you know a couple
hundred you know I don't know 500 000
worth of trade for Real Estate I'm got I
got serious debt I mean serious cash
hitting the bottom line every month and
then I added some income money to that
and I can reach over and buy another one
reach over and buy another one reach
over and buy another one and that thing
gets to moving and it does it feels like
it accelerates well then one emergency
the HVAC goes out a tenant some tenant
vacancy you're not freaking out yeah you
have a great position yeah I mean like I
don't know if something could happen
like covet where people don't pay their
bills nothing whatever oh wait that
actually happened yeah oh yeah that's it
and then you can't evict them legally oh
yeah that uh moratorium on evictions
yeah
and I'm not going to pay because there's
a moratorium on evictions and so good
luck with that landlord
I know but you know
house is paid for and when this is
lifted
you'll be homeless and I'll have a house
so that's what happened to a couple of
them they tried to play shyster and were
like yeah it didn't work out I had one
other come to me that was in a business
that was in a you know I had a script
Center and they came to us and said you
know we're in trouble can you help us
please give us some mercy and we went
yeah we can do that
and uh will you forgive the rent and I'm
like no but I'll uh stop collecting it
for now and you can pay it back later
so I mean we can just pay no payments
for four months and then we'll pay
double payments for four months or
something like that we'll work it out
with you because we're I mean I get
where you are and I don't want you to go
broke I don't want to be the guy calls
you go broke I'd rather you be alive and
and pay me the rent you know so let's
let's work it out I'll let's go no rent
for this month and we'll look at next
month no rent next month okay because
we're still got you know we still got
you're still getting fouchied so um as
long as you're getting fouchy dial I'll
try to help you and you have the margin
to do that because you had paid cash
payments you're not desperate you know
and we did have one tenant one time the
poor lady single mom got terminal cancer
and you know I have the margin to be
compassionate and not charge her and
just turn that house into a Ministry for
a period of time it's a horrible thing
horrible process she went through and
she didn't make it sad into the story
you know but you know but she didn't
have a landlord problem because her
landlord didn't have a mortgage problem
hello see how this works this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show for we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America we're so glad
you're here George Campbell Ramsey
personality host co-host of the smart
money Happy Hour podcast on the Ramsey
Network says my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five hey guys we need your
help
we do
if you would subscribe to the show or
follow the show it helps us considerably
so just click the button
if you'll share this show by telling
people it's here just go hey I listen to
this on talk radio hey I watch this on
TBN hey I or send the click the share
button or share the link
it really really helps us and leave a
five-star review that's very helpful
very helpful all of those things affect
all of the number of people that are
shown this show with the algorithms on
the internet and once they're shown it
then they get to decide if they think we
suck or not so we're glad when you help
us out thank you thank you very much
it's hey you you get all this for free
it's a way you can pay us back right
there you go William is in Atlanta
Georgia hi William welcome to the Ramsay
show
Mr Ramsey how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
I need some Uncle Dave wisdom
um I'll be coming into a pretty large
inheritance in cash and then about uh
three million dollars of it will be in
dirt uh so now that a lot of it is an
incredibly great location to create
Waterfront and over a thousand acres of
it can be farmed or logged to cover any
of the costs to own the land but at the
end of the day I do not want the land
because we moved away and I have had
these conversations with my father over
the years and and his parents generation
my grandparents made it clear that they
did not want my father to sell the land
and he honored that and my dad has not
put that request on me but I grew I grew
up you know hard in my family has worked
and to build uh from what we have from
nothing and I mean to my my first family
members when they integrated here farm
this slant so my question is am I
morally obligated in any way to keep
this land and because it was built and
expanded over the last four generations
no
you're not morally obligated unless you
gave your word to keep the land to one
of those air or one of those
predecessors your dad or your
grandfather
if you did if you did that you'd be
morally obligated to keep your word but
just the fact that it's uh got this
tremendous
Nostalgia to it is not a moral thing
it is a little heartbreaking
to think I mean and it probably hurts
your heart a little to think about
getting rid of it but on the other hand
you're like I can also know that just if
I keep it I've got all this hassle
Factor right
exactly yeah it's very it's a very
difficult thing for me to to even think
about because I don't want to be viewed
as I'm just cashing in right because it
really is not about that it's not about
just it's about
yeah uh the other option is
hassle factor and uh you know dealing
with it so you said it's one thousand
acres
it's over a thousand acres but a
thousand of it could be logged or farmed
to cover the cost of the entire estate
what is the total acreage piece
um it's
1500 okay where is it what what state or
area
it's up north in Minnesota Wisconsin and
Iowa
okay it's spread out and you're in
Atlanta
correct and you have another life
correct
hmm
okay
um
so the expense of owning the land is
property taxes and what else
that is it it's completely paid off it's
property tax is the only thing okay all
right and what's it worth
uh conservatively it's it's three
million and that's being conservative
it's probably even a couple Grand an
acre
okay so this is pretty rural stuff
um yeah but some of it is on the lake up
on Lake Superior so uh that that that's
really expensive uh so that would be
like resort property could be could be
resort property okay correct all right
and uh the rest of the inheritance that
you're receiving is another three
million in cash
yes sir
okay and what are you worth before all
this happens
um 250 000. okay and what do you make
uh between my wife and I 175 days okay
so you don't need any of this
correct and you don't need the money
um and just where do you want so you got
three million dollars you can place in
Investments and that's going to be
wonderful and this property is probably
not going to go up in value at the same
rate that normal Investments were
because it's fairly inexpensive rural
property with the exception of the
lakefront portion right
yes sir yeah
um
what do you want to do William
let's say you sell it and you get three
million out of it and now you have 6
million what is your plan or your dreams
my thought my thought would be
um I would like to think that my when my
family first immigrated here if they
could see what uh their descendants have
been able to amass I would want to take
it and then take that 3 million and
invest it into a rental complex of some
sort that's kind of where my brain is at
because I believe that we can actually
put that money to work rather than it
just be dirt and just sit there and not
do anything with it I would much rather
take it and
build something even greater for when my
wife and I have kids because I mean
we're still young we're you know 24
years old so I'll tell you I'll tell you
what I would do
um
there's no going back after you make the
decision
once you sell it it's gone forever
okay
so I'm gonna I'm gonna Push pause and
sit on it for a period of time and just
let this decision cook a little bit
so there's no regrets I don't disagree
with any of your questions or your
spirit on this
I completely agree with everything
you've said but I'm sitting here
thinking okay if you're 24 and the thing
sits there and you got plenty of money
and you pay the taxes on it and just sit
on it for three years
for two years and just let this decision
percolate
I I just I kind of think then you're
going to be really really sure
about what to do at that point uh and
you're going to have zero regrets in
other words you're gonna get really
disgusted and I'm getting rid of this or
you're going to get more nostalgic and
go you know I'm gonna ride this thing a
while
okay and I I'm gonna let this percolate
a little bit from the time it becomes
yours and your responsibility
I'm going to sit on it for at least two
years because you don't have to have the
money from it it's not killing you and
then you won't make the wrong a decision
that has a regret with it later the
the other option in there that you can
throw in is a partial
to keep some of it
carve out
200. and sell the rest or something to
where you've got an you know 200 out of
1500 yeah I mean wow wow it's a lot of
land
do something like that and then you've
got that piece of nostalgia that's not
enough that it's bothering you
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and answering is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
foreign
guys how many of you are thinking about
buying a home and you're cringing at the
thought of paying off debt for the rest
of your life like a mortgage for 30
years
you don't have to follow in that trap if
you need to borrow your Best Bets
actually a 15-year fixed rate where your
payments no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay it'll get you on track to
pay off your house fast a lot of people
pay off their home in less than 10 years
when they do that
just because they reach over and smack
that mortgage the free mortgage
calculator on our website can help you
it'll give you an idea what your monthly
payments could look like and that way
you'll know how much home you can afford
so that you can be mortgage free in 15
years or sooner go to
ramsaysolutions.com click free tools use
our mortgage calculator to get confident
about home buying again free tools at
ramsaysolutions.com Catherine's in
Daytona Beach hi Catherine welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call how are you better than I deserve
what's up
so my question for you is
gor my fiance and I are on baby step two
we're paying off debt we have one credit
card which I plan on paying off tomorrow
and then our car loan but
um
what I want to know I did both of you
sign on the car
it's just me okay then you're a car loan
because you're not married yet it's not
our
when are you getting married
um I'm I'm thinking probably next year
when we can get out of debt and or when
I can get out of debt and we can cash
flow in the wedding
how much are you gonna spend on the
wedding
um
I think we
I would stop everything and go get
married
you think so huh I'm positive
it's going to increase your likelihood
of your relationship lasting it's going
to increase the uh the the how fast you
get out of debt and you get to wealth
building anyway why'd you call how can
we help
um yes so
um my understanding is that we should
close all of our credit accounts we do
have a couple joint and we have a couple
individual
um like credit cards and everything and
get to that zero credit score before
trying to buy a home
but um we're just kind of
bumping heads when it comes to that he
believes that we should you know keep
the credit lines open not use the cards
just in case of an emergency and have a
buffer until we can get our fully funded
emergency fund
um built up completely so I guess my
question is like
what what can I tell him to get him on
board and if so what would the process
be like and what kind of time frame how
old are you guys you look at closing out
those accounts
um I'm 23 he's 33.
and what's his net worth
nothing
I don't have a number that yeah he
doesn't have any money
right
yeah so let's let's be clear we don't go
to a fat guy and ask them about physical
fitness so his opinion about this really
doesn't matter
because he's obviously wrong
am I wrong
he's broke
um you know so his theory is about money
suck
right
okay well do they or not I mean the
proof is in the pudding
he has no money so I mean when broke
people tell me their theories about
money it's laughable
it's when fat people tell me about how
to be physically fit it's the same thing
I have a keg if I go up to my uh on the
front of me my belly if I go up to my
personal trainer and he's got an eight
pack and I start telling him about
nutrition that's funny
you follow me
here's the thing there's a lot of traps
that he's fallen into that are cultural
everyone believes this and using your
credit card as an emergency fund to
borrow at 21 interest is about the
stupidest thing you can do so let me
just give you some facts because he's in
kind of this wonky reality uh simulation
right now here's what happens if you
have an emergency above a thousand bucks
you pause the baby steps and you go
cover the emergency you sell stuff get
side jobs do whatever you have to do
so that covers that one right but that's
not the only reason you said the credit
score correct
right
there's a thing called manual
underwriting when you go to buy a house
and you get a no score loan through
manual underwriting they look at your
full Financial picture your income your
debt to income ratio your down payment
and they give you a mortgage without a
credit score
now he can not believe it as if it's I
don't know the boogeyman or the Easter
Bunny but there's facts and data that
refute all of this and so I don't think
this is an intellectual discussion I
think this is a huge paradigm shift for
him to go oh I don't have to play the
games of a toxic money culture that says
borrowing is the key to wealth Catherine
you know why I was being so mean
why because she's 33 and you're 23 and I
think he's overbearing and I was trying
to give you some courage
he's wrong oh thank you
I think he's I think he's strutting
around like a turkey
and I think he's wrong and I want you to
stand up and and I want you to have your
voice in this relationship and both of
you have a vote because I think your
intellect is stronger than his on this
issue
and I don't think he thinks that am I
wrong just to be clear just to be clear
though we are not like coming at it in
an aggressive standpoint I just don't
want that image to come across I just
wanted to you're not coming at it I
don't know what standpoint say again
like an aggressive standpoint with each
other no I wasn't I wasn't saying that
but I don't I don't think he's listening
to you
okay I don't think it's aggressive at
all I think it's passive aggressive
possibly
but I mean I I really I mean I could be
wrong I could be wrong maybe maybe
you're the overbearing one but that
would be unusual when your 10 years is
Junior
it's possible I mean maybe you maybe
you're the stronger personality the two
that's possible but um that's why I was
doing that because I really want you to
I want your voice to be picked up in
this because I think he's discounting
your theories and it's making you
discount them and I think you're are
your theories or your approach the way
you want to handle this is not being
heard and he's kind of rolling his eyes
like little girl I got this
that's why I was doing that because I
I'm
I'm not okay with that process it's not
going to work out well for you
and I love both of you and I want you to
both to win and if he's on the phone I
would do the same exact thing so I want
you to I want you guys to you don't have
to be mean to each other or aggressive
with each other but his opinions are
wrong because he's broke
I I stand by my original statement but I
was being acerbic about it because I
really want to make sure that your voice
is being heard in this yeah and
Catherine I'm going to give you guys a
pre-marital counseling gift I don't know
that he's going to do it but I'm going
to gift you one year of Financial Peace
University I've got a class starting
next week that's virtual you can join
that or join a local class in your area
get in Georgia's class he's a lot nicer
than me and maybe I can talk to him face
to face that'd be fun yeah George George
will be kind and helpful as opposed to
me so there you go that could help so
hang on the line and Austin will gift
you guys one year Financial Peace
sometimes David takes a third party you
know if it's just the two people going
at it together it can be difficult when
you have a third party I'm a third and
sometimes I'm a party sometimes he's a
fourth Dave's a lot he is a lot but Dave
I heard this quote the other day maybe
you're not too much maybe they're not
enough I thought that was a fun little
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom just
like that yeah so this is a common thing
in a relationship but I guys honestly
when you're dealing with your family and
you're dealing with your friends or even
your spouse you know if you're broke
friends
are making fun of your financial plan
it's a sign you're on track
it's like you lost 30 pounds and your
obese friend is making fun of you
that
good
means you're on track okay it means
you're doing the right thing and so I
you know I don't give people advice on
growing hair on top of my head I'm not
good at it my track record is horrible
and so if you call me up and ask me how
to grow hair on top of your head I you
should not take my advice Dave's got it
getting rid of that George however
George has the do he has the do if you
wanna if you want to have the do you
could ask George about it because he's
the he's the dude nobody wants this much
maintenance in their life I don't have
any maintenance man my life is good but
but I'm still unqualified that's fair to
give you advice about growing hair on
top one thing I have on Dave there's
nothing I feel good nothing there I'm
just saying this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us America George
Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of
on the Ramsey Solutions I almost said
Financial Peace Plaza in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions headquarters is the
debt free stage and on the debt free
stage Leo and Paige are with us hey guys
how are you hi Dave better we deserve I
love it where do you guys live
Cincinnati Ohio fun welcome to Nashville
and how much data have you paid off we
paid off 140 000 and 37 months good for
you and your range of income during that
time it was 130 to 150. cool what do you
all do for a living I'm a data analyst
for an insurance company and I'm a CFO
for a credit union excellent very good
and how much what kind of debt was the
140. it was the mortgage
how old are you two
I'm 31. and I'm 28. and you have a paid
for house you're so weird very I love
you you're awesome you are so awesome so
what's this house worth
about three hundred thousand ah very
good yeah how much you got have you guys
got in your nest egg in your 401ks in
retirement and all that
about 170. okay wow you're getting there
yeah you're gonna be millionaires by the
time you're 35 then yeah
wow baby steps millionaires right in
front of me future ones anyway yeah yeah
good job YouTube I bet the folks the
credit union think you're crazy they're
like what are you doing man uh they
cheer you on yeah they did they did they
were very supportive uh there's one uh
one particular individual Chuck Stanley
I want to call him out he uh he was a
big uh inspiration yeah well I mean he's
the CFO of the credit union they got to
do what he says I I did free CFO is the
one I want to hire I'm just saying man
I'm just saying this is this is
incredible smart all the way around
excellent excellent excellent all right
tell us about your journey what happened
here
yeah we got married four years ago and
at that time he had paid off his student
loans about 62 000 and we came to
celebrate with you guys six months later
um I think it was opening of this
building something like that oh wow so
you did it at free scream already we did
you did yeah you did your your first one
and then you're doing one with the house
too that's right I like it
I like it yeah so then we saved up for
the down payment of the house got our
15-year fixed and closed on the house in
early 2020 and oh just in time yeah just
in time for some time to get fouchied
yes
all right and then 37 months later
you're not even 30 years old and you
have a paid for a house yeah so you
don't have any idea really seriously how
weird that is y'all are grinning like
you do but well we we wanted to make
sure there was flexibility when our
family tree changes and you know no kids
yet but we're hoping to change that hey
man
amen very cool good for y'all but I mean
that's you're statistically you're
highly unusual very I mean way up there
in the success module way to go man
thank you way to go and uh I mean with
the the you know the ability to make a
hundred and a half 200 a year that going
forward and not a payment in the world
the amount of wealth you're going to be
able to build is just basic compound
interest Matt you know the math as a CFO
it is going to be mindful of 10 10
million dollars I mean 20 million
dollars oh easy amazing this is wild so
what made you guys go all right we I
knocked out the student loans what if we
put a big down payment and we just
knocked this house out real quick were
you guys in unity from day one on that
we were I think it was mainly the
flexibility we want with our family
um
if I decide to work part-time whatever
we decide there we went at the
flexibility not to owe anyone anything
it becomes a short conversation with a
lot of Joy that's right instead of a lot
of stress of how are we going to make
this work yeah oh it's incredible man
that's so cool that's a great why good
for you well done very well done it's
it's one of the reasons that we lose our
team members
uh I was having breakfast downstairs the
other day uh with with my son who's the
president of the company and young lady
walked by with and stopped and tears run
down her face she said this is my last
week and I'm like well I'm so sorry
where you're going so I had my second
baby I'm going home I don't have to work
well that's good we don't want you to
leave because we need the help but
that's good if you're going to lose an
employee that's the way to lose one
right you know I mean wait that's pretty
cool you taught them stuff they changed
their life they don't need us
we got financial peace now Dave we're
good thanks yeah way to go you guys
that's exactly where you're going to be
right I mean that's you're going to be
that person that's that's where you're
set up to be because you've been smart
and you've been you've been careful uh
have you had a lot of encouragement
we've had some encouragement from
friends it's been um just mostly people
saying well I'm not sure if I would do
that but I'm happy for you guys yeah
y'all are a little weird yeah you are
weird statistically very weird but hey
by the way being wealthy is weird
statistically yeah we work like it uh we
work we work like it dependent on us but
we pray like it depended on God amen
amen well way to go all right what do
you tell people you're sitting here
everything's paid for you started this
off with a student loan you started the
marriage off you're on the same page
what is the key
to being a hundred percent debt free
house and everything before you're 30.
yeah I um I think a big part of it is
making sure you're on the same uh same
page with budgeting we've used every
dollar right from the beginning of our
marriage actually and to this day we
still use and we'll continue to use it
um one thing that also has helped is
you know if you feel like you got to go
A Thousand Miles and you take the first
couple steps
feels like you got a long way to go and
it it is a long way to go but it really
does help when you have a life partner
that you know can can be a cheerleader
and say hey
we're one step closer the goal exists
it's not just a mirage out there and
that's um that was a big one yeah you
got to really lay the math down so that
you know the light at the end the tunnel
is not an oncoming train that this isn't
a mirage yes yeah you know you don't you
don't want to go ah I'm barking I'm
throwing crazy this is crazy stuff no it
really does work I mean by the time I'm
28 I'm gonna have a paid fourth or under
thousand dollars oh my God it's right
where you're going to be I mean this is
pretty cool amazing yeah we're going
home to have a a mortgage burning party
with our uh friends and family so an
old-fashioned mortgage burning party Ah
that's good I like you to do it right
there you gotta like print it out now
and do a whole thing they don't even
send you in the mail anymore oh
absolutely oh it's summer you can take
your shoes off walk through the backyard
the grass feels different when it's
yours absolutely very much so very
different very different I love it guys
I'm so proud of you thank you all right
how's it feel to have no payments in the
world
feels like freedom freedom
Freedom that's it that's it Well Done
hey we've got the live and give box for
you that's got The Total Money Makeover
book you'll be able to give that away
the baby steps millionaires book that's
you very soon and a multi-millionaire in
the future and uh be sure enjoy those
two number one best sellers of Financial
Peace University membership you'll be
able to give that to somebody that's
inspired by your story your story is
inspiring you guys are heroes we're so
proud of you well done thank you thank
you very well done and hey I gotta tell
you man I like two debt free screams the
double one when you get rid of the
Consumer Debt come back when you knock
out the mortgage I'm in for both I'm
ready to welcome you back with open arms
I'm big on celebrating people who are
heroes well done good work good work Leo
and Paige Cincinnati Ohio 140
000 paid off in 37 months making 130 to
150 house and everything and they did it
before their 30. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
debt free
[Applause]
free love it
you too way to go
hey while everybody's doing layoffs out
there and firing people we're hiring
matter of fact I got to hire somebody
replace that young lady I was talking
about that was that was a sweet
Bittersweet conversation she was so
sweet and stand there talking to me and
you know the president of the company
and and uh been here several years and
very smart we will definitely miss our
talents but she's going home to be a mom
I mean there's not anything better if
I'm gonna lose someone out of here
that's how I want right yeah we got open
roles in marketing and technology and
sales and we need people like you to
come join us if you're a technology
person by the way we leave
at five and go home
we don't work 80 hours here
so you're working for some companies
working you like a dog now we don't do
that so this is way more than just a
radio show there's over a thousand
people in this building and we help
people get out of debt build wealth do
work that they love create quality
mental health and connected
relationships all with common sense and
very counter-cultural but good Lord it
doesn't take much to be counter-cultural
today check out all the open roles at
ramseysolutions.com careers
ramseysolutions.com
careers this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Luke 6 31 and as you wish that others
would do to you do so to them Mark Twain
says kindness is a language which the
deaf can hear and the blind can see
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Pat's
in Fort Lauderdale Florida hi Pat
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
okay thanks for having me and your staff
answer my email so I was calling in
reference to um I have I did the
financial peaceful University during
covet I paid off a rental home all my
debt credit card debt and my my car my
only debt right now is my um I'm sorry
my only BET right now is my my home that
I currently live in and my student loans
so I have a financial advisor that I
reached out to and I told him that I
wanted to pay it's only I only owed I'm
down to fifteen thousand dollars on the
student loans so I told him I wanted to
pay that off in the next year and he
feels that I should not do that instead
allocate that money towards my Roth uh
Ira so my question is do I go against
him do I go you know I don't know which
road to take
and how much do you owe on your student
loan
15 000. so I'm almost there
okay but I'm about to be 60 next month
and I still have a student on and I
don't want and next weekend I don't want
to have this over my head anymore
well you know what you need to do and
that's pay off those loans you have the
money to do it
well my goal was to pay them off and
um pay aggressively and get them done in
one year the 15. okay well here's the
thing it's kind of like going to a
dentist and saying hey do I have any
cavities that you think would need to be
filled the dentist is going to find some
cavities you know what I mean and so the
financial advisor wants you to invest
because that's how they make money and
they're not thinking about the full
picture in this case about your freedom
and your retirement and your goals and
your peace
okay
and I know that there's loan forgiveness
it's going nowhere so that's why I said
I had it and I just want to get this
done with so here's the thing
okay his his theory if I understand it
correctly
is that instead of paying off the 15 000
you should put the fifteen thousand into
his
Investments correct correct yeah and so
what he's saying is is that the student
loan he can make more on the money than
the student loan interest is does that
sound right
yes yeah okay so what if he came to you
and said uh what's the interest rate on
your student loan by the way Pat 4.25
okay what if he said I've arranged a
million dollar loan for you
of 4.25 I want you to borrow a million
dollars
and give it to me to invest because I
can make more than 4.25 on it
what would you do what would you do
what would I do
um
that I don't know I don't I'm not really
sure what to do would you borrow it's
not a trick question would you go borrow
a million dollars no at 4.25 so that you
could invest the money with him because
he says he can make more than that no
that's not a trick question I'm not
trying to catch you off guard but what I
am doing is just sometimes when you're
looking at a decision like this if you
add a bunch of zeros to the decision
it makes the principal become very
crystal clear
so let me tell you what just happened in
our conversation
okay when I made it not 15 000 but I
made it a million you felt the weight of
debt you felt the risk of debt and you
said I might actually intellectually
know that I might make more than four
percent but I'm not willing to take the
risk
that I won't I don't like the weight of
that that's what just happened in this
conversation wasn't it that's what your
brain did
am I wrong
no I got yes you're right okay and so
because it's only 15 000 it makes you go
well maybe he's right
but your heart is saying no no no no no
I want the peace
okay so I would agree with you I I think
he's wrong and I would pay off my
student loans and I also would consider
a different financial advisor because
he's not aligned with your value system
and how you see things
and his job is not to change your values
his job is to make suggestions you know
did you hear what you said you said do I
go against him
this is your money
yes you shouldn't be asking a question
about do I go against him he's not your
husband
he's a financial advisor
it should be going you know I don't
understand why he would say that I don't
want to do that and it makes me confused
that that's the way but you know but but
instead you're having to go but so what
else is he bringing to you that you
didn't catch
that's what bothers me and I'm not
saying he's a crook I'm saying he
doesn't agree with your way of seeing
the world and you should have someone
that says I agree with your way of
seeing the world that's why we tell
people you know Financial the smart
investor Pros they are aligned with our
way of seeing the world they're not
going to tell you to go into debt to
invest and if you say I want to pay off
the stats they're not going to go whoa
hold on we shouldn't do that you should
go invest in matter of fact they would
say yeah you should do that before you
talk to me and say come back in six
months when you're dead free exactly
exactly and I'll help you with your Roth
IRA then and I'll and you're a little
bit behind because you're 60 years old
so we need to get going they'll
encourage you right and that kind of
stuff but they're not going to put you
in debt or keep you in debt in order for
to align in order to do investing and
you know that guy could be doing that
with nefarious motives he could be just
because he wants a commission but it
could be he just really believes it's
the right thing and he's wrong
that's very much possible and I'm I'm
more scared of an enthusiastic ignoramus
than I am a con artist they can do some
danger yeah because I because they're
enthusiastic you know and um so yeah I
think you need to rethink who you're
taking advice from because it doesn't
align with your values
not because it doesn't align with mine
but because it doesn't align with yours
that's what's important and and so
you know I had CPA one time years ago
George we had when Ramsey was a small
company it was actually a friend and um
but uh he knew I had gone through
everything losing everything and I would
you know I'm now debt free and I don't
borrow money anymore he came in he's
kind of
he was kind of going to tell me how
things are kind of going to school me up
a little bit you know and you know well
you know I don't agree with you about
this whole debt thing and being debt
free and all that but we don't have to
be in agreement about that for me to do
your taxes oh boy
ought to be your CPA and I thought yeah
actually we do kind of do you know we
kind of a deal breaker because a CPA who
can't do math is bothersome you know
that's just a problem so I can't I can't
do that no it's not you know we cannot
be we can be friends we can hang out on
the weekend you're not doing my books
there's a big difference it's a
different thing here so yeah I mean I
got lots of friends who think I'm nutty
and I think they are but that's okay and
some are closer friends than others but
man yeah you know it's you know you're
not going to do that we have to be
aligned on this it's very important
folks that when you're dealing in the
financial realm that you get someone
with a heart of a teacher that's huge
and someone that actually explains to
you and doesn't just tell you okay dude
go do this because I said so they should
be slow methodical and go here's exactly
why they're making suggestions and then
you are still making the choice
that's a huge part of this don't ever
call the show and said the financial
advisor made me no you call the shots
you make the choices my guy lost all my
money nope
nope
you did
because you didn't make the decision
it's your it's your responsibility to
decide
this is the problem like when I'm
meeting with the guys in the NFL or
something they go I got me a guy I got
me a guy I'm like no no no dude you're
the guy
you're the guy that's a dangerous
sentence I got me a guy is what you say
right before all your money disappears
you know I know where I went yeah no
that guy's got used what's happening no
you you have to make your own decisions
that your financial your mortgage person
your insurance person your estate
planning attorney your uh your
investment advisor for sure are teachers
they give you ideas and advice and then
you decide
period that's the only way
good show George well done well done
that puts this hour in the book so we'll
be back with you folks before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]